girl of Steel here to tell you about the  sweetest alien ever no not me it's easy  the extra-terrestrial seriously we have  so much in common we both came to earth  in a spaceship well I guess they came in  a pot but what up we were also both  taken in by hearing Earth's family and  we're huge fans of disguises although  honestly a pair of glasses is all you  really need just watch  who's this it's Superman and that nope  no idea  also ETS superpowers too he uses them to  help those in need it's just like me  plus he has his phone like a crazy  coverage he can even call his crew  intergalactic botanists oMG a Kryptonian  we should totally certain alien Club  yeah now we're talking Oh  you could play bonus content first on  PlayStation